welcome everybody good morning Amsterdam
how are we all doing
yay this is the last session before
lunch so try and keep it light right
imagine you have a website could be any
website and
there's some traffic coming to it and
it's working fine
but at some point are you launch a new
product
I don't know iPhone or whatever and
there's a lot of people coming to your
website now and there's not enough
traffic being served and people are not
happy
what should happen is that we should use
what kubernetes been promising us right
the autoscaler you can Auto scale it but
it doesn't do everything by default
there's some work that we have to do in
order to do that and that's what we're
going to look at today how do we Auto
Scale based on some events and basically
scale out the website and let people do
what they need to do but before we start
because you've all come here I thought
we should reward you with something
everybody know this talks right the
Linux tux it's a Lego I have this Lego
right here we like like who likes Lego
yeah but everybody's not going to get
like that you know uh there'll be a bit
of a quiz just one question shout out
the number people know about the
landscape cncf landscape the cncf
landscape
no not that one
this one right so this this landscape
this shows you know we were talking
about Sarah was talking about this
morning about choices and how many
choices we have there's a lot of
projects on there
or cards so here's a simple question the
question is how many cards are on the
cncf landscape some of you might already
know this but I'm not unreasonable so
I'm going to give you a bit of a hint
this is what 20 cards look like right so
that's 20 cards for service mesh right
so here you go shout and number
whoever's closest my uh William here
will give you this so just shout a
number
400 400 higher
600 keep going up keep going up
one thousand keep going
1200 I think yeah let's let's stop here
one one seven four that's very good a
round of applause to that gentleman
there can you just
pass it on
1174 enjoy the Lego I don't know how
long it takes to make it but apparently
the instructions are as good as what we
see so just a few more things that's
1174 projects on there I I just put out
some more stats on here it's from it
says of last night
three six the 3.6 million stars but more
importantly like countless of community
Stars right people who are working on
these projects in their own time so
great and some some of the other stuff
there so this was as of last night uh
1174 but when I woke up this morning
it's uh it looks a bit like this it
keeps increasing every day right so but
I know you're a bit disappointed that
you didn't you didn't win uh maybe that
Lego but don't worry uh I work for app
gear and we have boots downstairs if you
like to win some of this stuff we have
some cool stuff to just come through we
are downstairs uh the mark Lucy and uh
um Rory are down there and I'm going to
be myself there so if you want to come
and have a chat I work for a company
called Appiah as an envelopes engineer
and we are a startup we are consultancy
we also have a product that helps you
deploy stuff to Cloud easier and also
work as a kubernetes instructor for
learnkades check out our website
learncase.io and we have some we have a
bunch of blogs you can find me on
Twitter at soul manikbar I also have a
bit of a YouTube channel you can check
that out so much
I have to make sure I put that there
because I need to get paid so we're done
with that but yeah so that's my YouTube
channel just check out my YouTube
channel but before I start really want
to thank the hosts and the organizers
you know they've done an awesome job
putting an event together would you
agree with that yeah
yeah
thank you thank you so much so and also
I want to thank my friend Daniela
palanches from learnkates who helped me
put together this uh this presentation
so thanks to Daniela so here's what
we're going to do brief look at services
and a quick look at ingresses I'm sure
you're already aware of what those are
but just to make sure we're all uh on
the same page and then we'll look at
cada how do we Auto scale it and then
I'm going to show you how to auto scale
the Ingress whatever I show you even
though we're going to scaling the
Ingress you can also apply to any other
workloads that you have so it should
work fine so imagine
uh just a just a bit of a quick recap
this is imagine a deploy a website and
uh it's just a static page and if you
want to deploy this in kubernetes
usually you deploy the website and you
have to stick in a load balancer because
you need to make sure the traffic is
distributed evenly and you can have
multiple load balances because you might
be running multiple applications inside
and then if you're running multiple
applications you want to make sure you
route the request based on the request
that they've sent to so in kubernetes as
we all know the internal load balances
are Services they pick the right pot to
send and then the the the the the top
layer load balancer is called in Ingress
so this is sending requests from outside
the cluster to inside the cluster and
then we have pods I'm sure we'll we all
know this so this is so this is what it
is we're going to focus on on Ingress
today but before I can talk about
Ingress it's important to just point out
really quickly what services are and or
the limitations of services in in the
context of running websites and do we
need Ingress so every time you deploy an
application inside a pod a container or
multiple containers gets an IP address
and then we use Service as an
abstraction layer because it's
convenient to uh to have an abstraction
layer we've sent a request from another
pod or from outside somewhere the
service knows how many pods live
underneath it and it can basically you
request you send a request to the
service and it's it's an abstraction so
that makes a request and only the
service knows how many pods are running
so you could have two uh and if if a pod
dies or comes back up it doesn't matter
it will keep track of it it'll pick it
and all if it goes up to 10 pods up or
down doesn't matter the Pod that is
sending a requests doesn't need to know
anything it's the service that needs
denied
so that's very high level service
definition uh if you would ask charges I
guess that's what it would give you
um but there's different kinds of
services we have a headless service
that's a building block and the most
basic service it's basically like all it
is just an endpoint the IP address it's
not very good with load balancing so
what what kubernetes also provides is
the default service so if you create a
service in kubernetes cluster IP extends
headlets kind of like a load balancer so
it does a better job than uh headless
for load balancing
then we have so the two services so far
they're all internal Services you can't
expose it to Dark Side cluster outside
of the cluster so then we have this
thing called node Port this external
service you it basically opens a port on
each node
but you might have multiple nodes
running so what kubernetes provides is
another kind of service called the load
balancer service and it it just has a
node port and if you're in a cloud
provider it Provisions an actual
a load balancer and attaches it to the
nodes if you're doing this on premises
that you've used a service type load
balancer you have to have some kind of a
project like metal lb that allows you to
do that but it's kind of useful if
you're doing with the cloud provider
there's a couple of things uh there
there's a few gotchas with uh
services
the good thing is it automatically
Provisions the the load balancer so
we're talking about external Services
because we want to make sure we can
access the website from outside of the
cluster it's automatic provisioning it
Provisions the nodes on the ports and
attaches it to the load balancer but as
I said it's cloud provider specific and
if you're doing on-premises yet there's
extra work you need to do and I don't
know if you have done this I'm pretty
sure you'll wear Cloud providers is not
cheap in the cloud in sorry load
balances are not cheap in the cloud
provider imagine if everybody's spinning
up a load balancer for their application
could be could cost a lot of money
and the limitation is it's basically
just layer four uh if you wish to expose
services that use TCP or UDP services
are good uh your application is good so
this is where we need something like
this an Ingress uh something that can
understand HTTP requests and can deal
with it and send the request to a
service and that's why we have the
service we have this Ingress that sits
on top of service I'm sure you will know
but that is what it is what we can do
within Ingress is we can root traffic
based on the requests that we make
for example in this I have this cluster
with multiple applications the red the
green and the yellow and you can do path
based routing so if somebody says
example.com forward slash account send
them to uh the the Reds the red pods if
somebody says forward slash checkout
send them to the yellow pod and so this
is where Ingress comes in quite handy or
also you can do subdomains like if you
need to do domain-based routing you can
do all of this so that's one Ingress is
right so that's the Ingress the pointer
of an English everybody happy so far are
we are we all good
okay cool
so
so far I've shown you Ingress as just a
black bar that's all it is and I'm sure
you already know this it turns out that
and Ingress is just a deployment a
regular deployment of depending on the
type of Ingress controller you pick
there's different English controllers
and a service usually load balancer or
node Port because you know it's like
external service so you can expose it
and in this diagram you can see that the
black bar has been disappeared has
disappeared and now we have this service
load balancer type and we have an
Ingress pod in this case we have nginx
you could pick any uh that you like
there's this menu and there's quite a
few which which Ingress controller you
should pick depending on what your
requirements are there is some there's
some research out there that you can
check out on learnkates.io
so it's basically a regular deployment
and Ingress comes in two parts you have
this thing called the Ingress controller
basically the pod that's running that
understands what to do with the rules
that you write and the rules are those
Ingress manifests that you write these
yaml files right so these yaml people
written the singular saml file before
right yeah have people written it one
person has in this room I'm sure there's
more than one ah good good excellent
people have written this right
um so this is this in Ingress is writing
the rules of defining what should happen
to the request where should it go to
which service should the request go to
so we write this yaml file and we submit
that to the kubernetes cluster the
cluster takes that request and it stores
the information inside a net CD database
and we have a couple of components in
here we have a scheduler of a controller
manager but that information goes in and
goes in goes ahead and gets stored in
the hcd database that's where we store
the state the desired State and the
current state and the controllers do the
magic and make sure the the state the
desired state the current state always
goes closer to the desired so that's
what it does but
when you deploy this rule the Ingress
yaml file the cluster itself will the
the Ingress pod the controller will spin
up it will get the information from the
Ingress because hcd and it will
configure the rules so nginx config if
you use nginx it will configure the
rules in nginx config to say if this is
the the Pod you need to send the request
to this service that's all it does right
and then it will just write or if you
write another another Ingress we'll take
that rule it will update its config and
it will understand this
so here's the thing if you're running a
website so that's Ingress and service
and that's our backstory but if you run
a website now we understand the request
has to come from outside of the cluster
so it has to go via the Ingress pod in
this case it's nginx if it goes by the
nginx part and if a lot of traffic comes
in you might end up with a bottleneck if
you have just one replica running
you might say hey uh uh what should
happen is that if if a ton of traffic
comes in we should scale out
you might say oh maybe I can just start
with the 10 Ingress pods running at all
times which is fine you can do that uh
but of course it's going to cost you
money so if you want to save some money
in these times
especially in the UK because the pound
is very down we need to make sure that
we can scale down when we need to
so what you can do as I said in Ingress
the deployment is a normal deployment
you can configure this if you deploy it
in your cluster as a Helm chart or
whatever it is you can configure these
settings you can change these settings
you can say there's there's a file in
here there's a line in here called
replicas I can open the file change it
to three replicas and submit it to
Cluster and I'll have three replicas but
it's not very scalable it's not very you
know you have to maybe you have to wake
up at 2 am in the morning we need we
need something good right we we don't
want to wake up to him in the morning we
want it to happen automatically so this
is enter our helper the horizontal pod
Auto scaler
it's a resource in kubernetes that
scales out the pods the vertical pod
Auto scaler is different it changes the
CPU and memory so it can increase more
CPU in memory for horizontal portal
descaler spins up more pods
so you can see this in this case what
should happen is imagine there's a
deployment for the Ingress we've
deployed we deployed this Ingress
controller in our cluster and it's
running with three replicas
well horizontal pod Auto scale can do is
it can query some Metric let's say
number of active connections inside each
pod right that sounds like a reasonable
reasonable metric let's say you can
query that metric and we can write a
rule we can say hey if each part is has
got more than 100 connections we need to
scale up
a reasonable request let's say
then what should what horizontal Port
autoscaler do it does is it will do its
calculation and if you breach the
threshold it will automatically adjust
the deployment and it can it can scale
up add another pod and scale back down
and remove all the pods that we that we
don't need
so what we want to do is Scale based on
incoming traffic
with me so far everybody good
I know it's 15 minutes to lunch so
we we're on track don't worry we're on
track
so what we want to do is we basically
want to scale on HTTP requests coming in
basically the request is coming in but
you can do it on any metric you prefer
in our case we'll just do it on let's
say active connections so we first of
all we need to have metrics available
and we need to expose it so the
horizontal pod Auto scaler can take
those metrics and do something with it
so usually you would write in in your
application you do forward slash metrics
and you can write key value pairs in
there and just in your application make
it available so something like
Prometheus can can scrape it
but we take that metrics we need to
store those metrics because you know the
requests have to come over time we need
to store it just run our calculation and
then once we store it so collect and
store it and then we're going to do auto
scaling we have based on those metrics
we'll write some rules and we'll Auto
scale and this is what you see in the
demo as well
so uh what we have is luckily for me it
makes the demo easier nginx provides
already some metrics that's so I don't
have to write anything from scratch and
your next pod has forward slash metrics
it provides these metrics in here we can
take this metric nginx connections
active so this is all the actual
connections coming in that's what we're
going to take
they're available but we need to scrape
the metrics so what we can do is we can
use Primitives people like Prometheus
here anybody like Prometheus yeah we've
got it's a great project right so we
basically what it does is it helps us
you have something called a metrics
server in kubernetes that that can that
can be that can be used to pull out the
metrics from whatever resource that we
want to pull out from you takes it off
from cubelet and provides it to other
resources like horizontal pod Auto
scalar
and this is where we can use Prometheus
Prometheus allows us in Prometheus we
can scrape the metric and then store it
whatever we like in this case we're
going to store it in something else but
what we're going to use is Prometheus
you don't have to use Prometheus but in
this in this one we're going to use
premises and I have a cluster that's
running locally which has parameters
already installed
and then we're going to use this project
called cada or Kita kubernetes event
Driven Auto scaling have people heard or
use this project oh yeah excellent we
have quite a few people
so if if we get stuck you can come up
and you know give me a hand if the demo
doesn't work but it should be good so
here's the thing we need to expose the
metrics we need to store them
so we can scrape it using Prometheus we
need to store the metrics and then we
basically needed some kind of an adapter
that can take the information and feed
it to the resource metrics so we can we
can act upon that and then we need
something that scales based on requests
coming in to coming in from from
wherever they're coming in
and this is where we can use this uh
cader kubernetes event Driven Auto
scaling I'll show you in a second uh a
couple of diagrams for what it looks
like it lets you basically Drive the old
scaling of kubernetes based on events
events that happen inside the cluster or
events that happen outside the cluster
too which is amazing if you have a bunch
of requests outstanding in a Kafka queue
you can scale on that so there's a bunch
of scalers that KDA already provides
that we can plug into even stuff like
SQL queries run SQL query if the result
is above some number
do something with it so that's where
we're going to use cada what we can do
is quite flexible it's open source and
it drives the horizontal pod or the
scalar something needs to feed all this
information to the horizontal pod Auto
scaler to be able to scale it and that's
what we're going to use kdap
what is it so we have the metric server
as I talked about before just briefly is
used to collect metrics from cubelet so
the cubelet that's running on each node
it collects metrics from there and
exposes it to the kubernetes API and it
plugs into the aggregator API but what
we have is this metric server
it's not enabled by default so you have
to enable it but when you install with
the in K9 cluster it will be enabled
and then we need an adapter which you
know Prometheus adapter same
um Cade also provides one it can collect
and serve custom metrics to an external
metrics to the horizontal portal to
scaler okay that has it
and a controller that sits in the
cluster and acts upon the vents
so that's that's what we need so if the
controller is there we're going to have
a bunch of custom resource definitions
so things that with things that cater
defines and I'll show you an example of
that and
controller is something that extends
kubernetes and does a functionality and
then we have
what are called scalars we're not going
to talk about them today but this is I
briefly mentioned it
um you know if you for example you can
based on you can Define some rules based
on requests coming in from rabbitmq you
can scale out your application or
there's a lot of cloud watch events like
AWS cloudwatch anything in Pub sub in
the cloud provider it's very neat and
it's quite easy to set up and so this is
where cada is cada comes in handy and
that's what we're going to do a demo on
so we have 10 minutes so a lot can go
wrong in 10 minutes but so that is the
demo uh we're going to do live if it
fails
I have a video as well but we'll pretend
it was live if it if it failed but I'm
sure it'll work so you can if you want
to check out Danny Elliot wrote the blog
for this bit.ly forward slash kcd
scaling and run John minicube you can
run it yourself or you can run in any
cluster you like
um so that's that's where that's where
explanation and and the code and
everything is there so definitely check
that out so what I got which I'll show
you in a minute is a mini Cube cluster
is running I've installed Ingress nginx
Ingress on it already because I do not
trust the internet during demos so it's
already running and I've also installed
Prometheus and cada uh I've used hum for
it but you can install however you like
it's just one command line spins up the
pods I'll show you the pods in a second
and then what we need to do is we need
to have a way of generating some load
right because otherwise you'll think I'm
making it up so we're going to use com
uh Locust it's an open source project to
just generate some load and hopefully if
everything works we should see scaling
Auto scaling Ingress so are we ready for
the demo
less mirror
we'll give it a second for it to pop up
all right
we're cool here so here's a few things
that we got which I'll put actually put
in around
so this is all real there's a deployment
file I've deployed uh Stefan's pod info
pod I'm sure you've seen this is running
and everything is running locally uh
I trust internet but not during demos so
everything is running locally so that's
the pod that's running
has a service of course as well
so pod and a service I don't know if
it's big enough but let me is that is
that good the reasonable size cool so we
have service and a pod that's already
deployed and we have an Ingress and in
Ingress you can see there's a there's a
bit of a the rule here example that goes
to example if if the request is for
example.com send it to the Pod info
service so I'm not making any of this up
because if I can do a clear k get pods
you can see in a second there's some
some stuff running so we have um we have
our deployment here the podium for
deployment we have kader I've also
installed K down here the operator is
running and we got a bunch of crds to go
with it and we have uh pod info
sorry we have nginx Ingress running and
we've got some of the Prometheus stuff I
know no kubernetes demo is complete
without running Cube CT or get pods so I
just wanted to get that out of the way
so that's done now we can we don't have
to look at this instead of me showing
you lines we have a dashboard here right
so these are all the pods that running
in the cluster uh let me see if I can
zoom in
these are all the pods they're running a
cluster it's not uh it's not a photo
it's an actual like dashboard and we
have one nginx uh pod running so that's
all good I'm going to put that to the
side
and we're gonna
step onto here
and Prometheus is also running we've got
five minutes which is good but that's
all we need and let me just quickly zoom
out for a sec if I execute this this is
nginx ingress active connections
basically what we're talking about you
can't see this is quite small but
there's only one request because there's
only one request that was running
and then what I've also deployed is
Locust and Locust is an open source
project okay let's just open this and
all that has got is got its own
deployment but in here you can define a
config map and the config map we're
defining you have this Locust file the
py that's written in Python but you can
give it a task and all this is doing is
allowing me to send requests to
example.com that's all it's doing I want
to send request to example.com and
because it's Locust I can do a bunch of
things I can give the host that I need
to send a request to how many users I
want to send per second and what's the
what's the so what we can do is we can
start swarming The Host
we can start sending requests let's hit
on the chart uh uh I don't know if it's
uh let's just do this is this
is stats
there's some something's about to go
wrong bound to go wrong but let's go
there you go charts
okay so let's go hundreds what was it
which is going to stick here and also
what we have
is uh
let's go with that
I think I need this nginx Ingress
and spawn concurrency is 10.
so it should uh start sending requests
right so it start started started
sending requests and I should see some
of the requests go up on here in a
second we'll have more requests for
Ingress active connections outstanding
so if I just quickly do a refresh here
sometimes it will come up in a second so
basically what we've got is number of
users are increasing our requests are
going in and the response time will keep
going up
but what we need is to scale up so for
that we have to Define this code
something called the scaled object which
is a crd and in here I'm saying what
kind of deployment I want to Target the
main nginx Ingress deployment and I just
Define how many replicas I need and
we're Gathering metrics from from
Prometheus because that's that's where
it's scraping it from this is the one
I'm looking for the metrics that's the
name and the query is this all we're
saying is if the nginx Ingress
connections active is more than 100 so
that's the threshold do your scaling do
you think
so let's just see if I can execute this
you can see in here it's a very faint
line on on the edge there but there's
there's a number of uh requests there
going in there's only one now we're
going to focus on this part here what
we'll do is deploy the scaled object and
we should see
a number of nginx PODS increase if it
does go wild if it doesn't still go wild
Let's uh let's let's do this we're gonna
do a minus F4 we'll apply the scaled
object
what this will do is okay that's created
and what this will do is we'll look at
the metrics and it will start increasing
uh okay get deployed let's just do that
it should eventually start increasing
the number of pods
let's just make sure there you go the
pods have started to spin up and it will
spin up based on the request that we
said right so no yeah we've got it
working we got there
so this is as you can see now on here
the total number of requests are going
down because we scaled up based on the
request but based on the based on an
event
and if I keep this running uh once all
the traffic's served it'll scale back
down that's where the scaled object is
and you can do this for not only Ingress
you can do this for any any workload
that you might need
so uh I'm just going to do one last
thing
if you if you want to let's just hop
back on this
okay
where's my point uh let's go in here
all right let's go
so that's what you saw you saw us gather
some metrics and we just talked about
Services ingresses then we expose some
metrics and we gather them we kubernetes
doesn't do this by default there's a lot
of work we have to do to get all of this
running and you saw that if you want to
try it try it out as I said it already
is a Blog for this bit.ly forward slash
kcd scaling check out learnkates.io IO
we do we have some awesome blogs in
kubernetes and we do some training as
well to check that out also check out
appear.io if you have any questions or
anything like that I'm downstairs all
day this is our booth in one of the
areas come and grab me let me know if
the if it was useful or not if you want
to stay in touch with me my name is
Salman Iqbal you can find me on Twitter
at soulman or also YouTube but apart
from that thank you so much have a great
day and a great